I have something more important than
courage
I have patient they don't have enough
patience they don't allow enough time
for momentum to build up and they quit
patience is for the impatient rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's start your day off right together
grab your cup of coffee and sip on
today's message be patient over to you
Michael Jordan
[Music]
look manana it's okay if you're scared
so am i but we scare for different
reasons I'm scared of what I won't
become
you scared of what I could become
look at me
I won't let myself in where I started
I won't let myself finish where I began
I know what is within me
even if you can't see it yet
[Music]
look me in the ass
[Music]
I have something more important than
courage
I have patient
I will become what I know I am
[Music]
most entrepreneurs are patient enough
most entrepreneurs end up losing their
business they end up shutting down
because they think it's gonna happen in
a couple months or even six months or a
year and really it's gonna take them
four years five years before they hit
their mark they don't have enough
patience they don't allow enough time
for momentum to build up and they quit
and they end up going back to a crappy
job that they hate and maybe never ever
take a shot again in entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them
we're really they missed out you missed
out on your destiny you missed on
creating something amazing because you
just didn't have enough patience now I
believe in patience in the macro I
believe in patience and knowing it's
gonna take a long time I also think
impatience can serve you greatly but
that's in the micro that's in the daily
the impatience of did I do my best today
did I do my best today can I do better
can I Drive more can I Drive harder and
knowing that even if I give my best
every single day it's still gonna take
time it's still gonna take a number of
years for something to happen I wanted
to happen as soon as possible I'm gonna
drive and being patient as crazy to get
it going but I know it's gonna take time
- its embracing both that's when you
start to win I look at my my youtube my
Instagram my social media strategy
YouTube 70,000 subscribers four years
ago 1.2 million subscribers now four
years by making videos every day every
day
and I mean patient is anything because I
want it to be amazing I want to make
every video better than the last and
looking for all the hacks and SEO and
thumbnail strategies and title
strategies and all the stuff that we're
supposed to do right I'm on top of it
and I know that it's gonna take me four
years to get there I know it's gonna
take me a while to get to my next two
million five million ten million I look
at Instagram follow me on my Instagram
journey I'm starting from nothing you
can see how to build it up from zero I
had 8,000 followers and many of you
already have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm gonna make daily consistent content
three to four times a day for four years
I'm going to be in patience anything in
that the post today
to be amazing has to be something that I
want to show my grandkids right that's
the intent every time I create anything
I want my grandkids to watch this video
uh my grandkids to watch the next
Instagram thing that I put up it's the
best that I can come up with in the
moment and I know it's gonna take me
four years maybe three years maybe two
years but it's not gonna take me two
months I realize it's gonna take working
hard and working smart together always
quick story as a buddy of mine who's an
entrepreneur and every morning we check
in with each other we're both on our
goal to have accountability around
eating certain um of calories so we have
calorie targets for ourselves and every
morning we check in with each other and
the max we can be as over by 50 or under
by 50 we gotta stay in that range and
this morning he sends me a message to
say I'm cutting my calories at 1700 I
need to lose weight faster and I wrote
back to him and say don't be stupid
don't be stupid this is the problem
because you're gonna stick to that for
about a week and you're gonna realize
it's insanely difficult it's too hard to
keep up and then you're gonna go eat a
crazy huge pizza followed by Oreos
followed by McDonald's followed by all
this other junk you can avenge out
you're gonna fall way off track more
important than cut your calories down to
some extreme amount it's be consistent
you're just not consistent enough stick
to a higher target but do it daily this
is your problem - you're not consistent
enough more important than trying to go
crazy for one week and expecting magic
to happen is to do the hard work daily
consistently for four years and so he
started laughing I said don't be stupid
I want you to write that on your mirror
write that on your mirror when you wake
up don't be stupid today and he started
laughing and says you're right but
that's the problem that's the human
condition we're looking for the magic
bullet we're looking for the secret
sauce we're looking for that hack and
that shortcut
to try to eliminate the years of work
and I I agree with it I love it I love
that as a strategy I love before our
work week concept in the book I loved
hacking things I loved efficiency I'm
constantly looking at how do I shortcut
a five-year plan down to five months
always always always in forever and
through
and insane patience to know that things
will still take time not using it as a
limiting belief to say that I can't make
this happen faster but also recognizing
that that exists so that I don't get
defeated I don't get beat down and I
give up on my dream because I didn't
have the patience to stay the course I
think entrepreneurs in general are great
I'm looking for the hacks we're great at
the impatience if I didn't think that
that's what I'd be preaching I'd be
preaching in patience get after it let's
go shorten the cycle I think we're great
at that I don't think we're great enough
at the patience patience the long game
understanding if you stick with it if
you stick with it if you stick with it
even if you don't see any immediate
results even if you're hacking and
learning and getting better and you
don't see results and people say you're
crazy and people think this is never
gonna work out and sometimes you doubt
yourself as well if you stick with it if
you have patience you will win now I've
got some really special bonus clips for
you but before that my question of the
day I want to know what is the hardest
thing that you have right now in being
patient about whether it's getting new
clients whether it's building a fall in
a social media like what's the hardest
thing that you you have to wrap your
head around being patient I would love
to hear from you share the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
let's pray so give me go
patience is for the impatient that in
fact when you're getting started in your
in-laws are making faces at you and
you're not sure if you're gonna be able
to pay the rent and you don't know why
you're living in Brooklyn to begin with
and you're gonna have to move back to
Florida it's easy to say you know what I
need to go faster to pick up these
scraps to pick up these scraps and
sometimes what that does is it gives you
the foot up to get to the next level but
sometimes what that does is it just
makes you a scrap collector and that one
of the things that we see when we look
at the work of people who have put
really big ideas into the world who have
built online platforms right is that
they got there by being patiently
impatient or impatiently patient
whichever way you want to just oppose it
that if you look around at the blogs you
read or that the people you respect
online or the organizations you want to
work with the myth of the overnight
success is just that a myth that you
know the much-vaunted Twitter was a
failure a complete failure for two years
nobody used it and if they took the
mindset of well if it doesn't work in
two weeks we got to go do something else
you never would have heard of it 12
years ago today I asked somebody on my
team to run to Best Buy pick up a little
canon camera set it up I picked three
bottles of wine and put them on a table
I filmed it first time I've ever filmed
anything with the purpose of anybody
seeing it hello everyone and welcome to
the first episode of Wine Library TV and
it started the process of where we are
here today twelve years later
[Music]
when I hear people lacking patience or
wanting it so fast or not understanding
the marathon I've basically been
producing content for the internet for
the last 12 years and and I really wish
so many of you could understand how
quick that's gone and how much longer I
have to go but most of all realize how
much didn't happen in those first
several years
[Music]
how much I needed to persevere and build
an audience how much engaging and
replying to people along the way and
building relationships and hugging and
kissing babies and grinding and
believing and and most of all what's so
interesting is I sit here right now
outside this airport knowing that 65% of
you didn't know who I was 24 months ago
15 months ago that my current place of
attention is a current phenomenon
it's a 1516 month phenomenon that things
kind of took a little bit of a hockey
stick moment which means 10 and a half
years 10 1/2 of years of grinding and
putting out stuff and wanting to share
my thoughts unwind on business
entrepreneurship day in and day out day
in and day out Wow I worked all the time
building businesses while this wasn't
even my full-time thing I have so much
empathy that you want it I've so much
everything you want for you to get yours
but Jesus this doesn't happen overnight
dedicate a certain amount of time to the
business two hours a week four hours a
week 50 hours a week no matter what it
starts to compound after the year one
after year two after year three if you
dedicated two hours a week to you know
this new hobby or love or you know
business you know at the end of the year
it's over a hundred hours put in don't
be in a rush first we'll learn all the
mistakes early and then have some kind
of strategy know that this is where you
want to be after year 1 2 3 4 & 5 and
you have to really be honest with
yourself is the business worth it is it
costing too much because you'll know
raise your standard value
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details